da kommt sie zur literatur festival
cosmopolis in barcelona vs lass ihn 2013
steigt sie mit ihrem ersten roman in die
top liga der internationalen literatur
szene auf die schriftstellerin mit
britischen pass hat eine multikulturelle
herkunft die sich nicht einfach auf den
punkt bringen lässt
die lange antwort lautet ich bin in
london geboren ich wuchs in den usa vor
allem in massachusetts auf wurde in den
staaten und in england ausgebildet meine
mutter ist nigerianerin mein vater ist
aus ghana ein ghanaischer vater lebte
die meiste zeit seines lebens in saudi
arabien und meine nigerianische mutter
lebt heute in ghana
das geht zwar landkarte meines bei crans
aber ich weiß nicht ob es die frage
beantwortet woher ich komme
ihre herkunft ist typisch für viele
junge afrikaner ihre wurzeln liegen in
afrika aufgewachsen und ausgebildet aber
sind sie in der westlichen welt politik
nennt arcelor
2005 in einem essay und schafft damit
ein wir gefühl für eine generation die
sich aufgrund ihrer biografie zerrissen
fühlt
ich bin nicht wirklich als amerikanerin
akzeptiert wenn jemand sagt roll
american girl einen semi mich dasselbe
ironischerweise und vielleicht noch
tragischer in ghana dasselbe in nigeria
also wird sich auf mit dem ständigen
gefühl gesagt zu bekommen was ich nicht
will da kam ich an den punkt wo ich mich
fragte okay was bin ich also
wer bin ich die hat mich das land meiner
eltern geprägt
afro politische literaten mit theo koll
beschäftigen sich gerade verstärkt mit
ihrer herkunft auch selassie stellt in
diese dinge geschehen nicht einfach so
die frage nach der identität
natürlich habe ich eine identität ich
habe erfahrungen familiengeschichte ich
bin jemand ich habe halt keine identität
die in die verfügbaren kategorien den
gängigen schubladen passt
selassie sucht die öffentlichkeit wie
hier auf dem festival um sich über
heimat herkunft und klischees
auszutauschen
und die jehle und oxford absolventin
nutzt ihre auftritte um eloquent und
klug über rassismus heute nachzudenken
und mit vorurteilen aufzuräumen
rassismus ist ein denksystem wurzelt in
der fiktion der rassen
wenn wir von anfang an von der prämisse
ausgehen dass da eine fundamental andere
art von menschen es die wir als schwarze
kennen wenn wir davon ausgehen sind wir
umgehend im rassismus
denn es ist nur ein winziger schritt von
du bist eine andere sorte mensch hinzu
und dafür verdienst du eine komplett
andere behandlung
auch die etikette afrikanische literatur
nervt alle selassie denn was heißt schon
afrikanisch bei einem so heterogenen
kontinent auf spurensuche geht selassie
auch mit der kamera sie zeigt als
fotograf in ein ebenso viel gewichtiges
afrika wien ihren büchern
gisela sie sieht sich als erzählerin die
mit verschiedenen medien arbeitet aber
können geschichten tatsächlich
vorurteile abbauen
ein weg zur veränderung ist die sprache
der unvergleichliche autor james baldwin
hat mal gesagt sein dass man durch
schreiben die art wie menschen denken
verändern kann wenigstens ein bisschen
das könnte ein machbarer weg sein auch
wenn ich das natürlich als
schriftstellerin
erklärt das den erfolg von tarik asis
buch es wurde in 24 sprachen übersetzt
verkaufte sich auf deutsche rund 100.000
mal ein nigerianische genesis
kosmopolitischer familienroman vieles
erinnert an selassie es eigene
geschichte am lesen spürt man es spielt
keine rolle ob die figuren schwarz oder
weiß sind
momentan schreibt eine selassie in ihrem
zweiten roman worum es geht verrät sie
nicht
doch er spielt in berlin dem ort an dem
die weltbürgerin seit fünf monaten liebt